hello everyone and welcome back to the
last day of the superbed blitz
tournament currently being played in
Poland it is Magnus Carlson versus
Wesley so and it was really hard to
choose the game to show because Magnus
uh completely obliterated the field on
the last day uh this is what uh what
happened at some point he just woke up
and he just started demolishing everyone
if not for Bogdan Daniel Dak he would
have adopted the the the field of World
Elite Class player so that is absolutely
incredible if you guys have any other
games that you enjoy to do this hashtag
suggestion and I will gladly go over
them but now let's uh check out this one
Magnus is facing Wesley Seoul who is an
incredibly strong opponent in any time
format and you never know how the game
will go so let's check it out and Magnus
again does not bore us with his opening
choices he goes for Pawn to B3 the Nim
Soul arson attack he pretty much played
everything in this tournament he played
Ponto B4 I mean uh excellent stuff so
here we have Pawn to D5 the standard
names of Larson attack Knight to F6
Bishop to beat you and pawn to C5 Wesley
treating this very uh you know in a
classical manner just controlling the
center with pawns as a white decided not
to do we have fun to E3 Pawn to E6 and
Bishop to B5 check we have Knight B to
D7 Magnus castles and Wesley ghost spawn
to A6 chases away the bishop Magnus goes
Bishop to E2 and now there is a game
where Bishop to D6 was played between
guyarmada and Salis Salem I was played
in
um uh in Dubai two years ago the game
ended in a draw but here we have bishop
t7 and it is now already as of move
seven that we have a completely new game
so okay Ponta C4 makes sense you want to
have a strong central presence and you
want your Bishop to be
on the strong diagonal we have castles
and now C captures on D5 we have ninth
captures on D5 and now Knight the C3
offering a trade of knights Wesley goes
for its captures and now D captures now
Magnus wants to move the queen Place C4
and put the rooksa on the D file so that
definitely makes sense B6 and now Queen
to C2 with Bishop to B7 wasteless Bishop
also Now Incredible Rook after D1 and
now Queen to C7 uh getting away from
that D file and preparing to bring the
Rooks into the game with Bishop to D3
Magnus puts pressure on the H7 pawn and
the Wesley defends it with Pawn to G6
and now a very instructive maneuver by
Magnus as Now by playing G6 Wesley uh
really
uh well he he really limits the power of
the bishop on D3 whereas his own bishop
and B7 is still very strong so Magnus
just trades it uh we're a slight Square
Bishop for a better light Square bishop
and okay uh we have Pawn to C4 Wesley
even offers a pawn by you don't really
want to capture this Magnus does trade
Bishops captors captures but he doesn't
of course capture the pawn because then
let's say the Knight comes to C5 and the
the blockade here is just terrible for
white you have a bad Bishop now and
you're not really getting anything so
Rook to D4 now threatens Rook captures
on C4 and the Wesley captures some B3
captures captures and Bishop to F6 and
you really don't have any uh good
squares for the Rook along the D file
like you could try D6 but it seems a bit
too adventurous for a Blitz game uh and
you you don't really have any any use
for for The Rook on H4 on F4 maybe but
again not not nothing spectacular so
Magnus just goes back roof to D2 and now
he prepares the double up Rooks on the D
file we have Knight to C5
end Pawn to C4 now the ones are nicely
placed and you offer a trade of Bishops
so Wesley trades this bishop as well
captures captures and The Rook 838 and
it seems like Wesley avoided all of the
trouble he managed to trade on at pretty
much everything and now if he can trade
the Rooks off uh should be a fairly uh
clean draw some Road capture 78 we have
Rook capture 78 and now you might expect
something like B4 not just because you
follow what happens on this channel but
also because it's a nice move but
magnets go spawn to H4 he just wants to
go after that black king and since you
have a queen on this diagonal uh you
know that if this pawn reaches H6 the
game is pretty much over so Queen to E7
uh we have Pawn to H5 and now Wesley
goes for something that no one wants to
play and that is g captures on H5 and it
makes sense because like I said you
don't want to see H6 on the board even
even if it's okay it's a bliss game
imagine a 5h6 you have to defend
Checkmate now Queen to f8 and maybe okay
it's possible you are defending
Checkmate maybe even you you know you
can dream of something like 97 night
somehow comes to F6 then to G4 then you
actually win that pawn it's possible of
course uh but you know you don't have
all the time in the world to calculate
this so obviously just captures the pawn
and now Queen to E5 Magnus centralizes
the queen offers the B3 Pawn for the A6
pawn and also puts pressure on the H5
pawn and the Wesley could just ignore
this he could just play A5 and keep the
tension with Knight captures on B3 but
he goes for it right away Knight
captures on B3 Magnus captures an A6
Queen to C5 now offering a queen trade
and now Queen to G3 checked by Magnus uh
King to f8 and not Knight the G5 Knight
the E5 is more precise but again Blitz
sonai G5 and now Wesley has to play
Queen to F5 but he plays H6 because the
pawn was hanging and now Magnus gets a
crushing attack Knight H7 check King to
E7 Rook to A7 check with Rook to D7 and
now Queen to H4 with check interestingly
Rook the A8 is very scary for black as
all of the squares have been taken by
the rook and by the Knight and if this
Pawn is pushed let's say the E4 and D5
that black king is completely doomed
there on E7 but okay Queen th4 was
played with King to D6 and now Queen to
F4 with check Magnus continues the king
hunt Queen to F6 checking to D6 and now
he trades Rook counter skin captures and
just Queen captures on F7 with check
those are all isolated pawns so Magnus
uh of course knows that he's going to
make quick work of them so Queen to E7
Knights the F6 with check King to d8 and
now Queen to G6 of course declining the
queen trade uh we have Knight to A5
going after the pawn here and Magnus
just collects Queen captures on H6
Wesley does the same Knight captures on
C4 and Knight captures on H5 Magnus is
now up a pawn but Wesley has a very
dangerous past B Pawn so of course he
starts pushing it pawn to B5 we have
Knights the F4 uh King to B7 getting the
King off of any nasty nasty checks uh we
have Queen to H5 going after the pawn
here and just King to C6 defending the
pawn with the King uh Queen to F3 with
check and King to B6 now Wesley is
hoping to get his King down the board
and then even escorted the pawn uh using
the king
amongst the queen and Knight so here we
have Queen to E4 putting pressure on the
E6 spawn and now uh Wesley uh can even
play Queen to F6 here and it's gonna be
uh pretty good because it's a very hard
to avoid Queen to A1 check and for
example if capture with the Knight Queen
T1 checking H2 and queen to E5 forces a
queen trade and then at some point the
magnets will have to give up the Knight
for this spawn so it's hard to say uh
you know play to Perfection of course uh
should be a draw uh but it's uh probably
Wesley's best chance here but he played
King to A5 and now we have Knight
captures on E6 Queen to B4 uh and now
Wesley just runs into a forced Checkmate
in seven but it's Blitz Magnus misses it
of course he played Queen to C2 the
fourth Checkmate is Queen to A8 check
and it's always uh terrible when you
miss something that starts with check
because it's like everyone knows it's
the first um okay first you check if
it's possible to capture something then
the next thing you check if it's
possible to give a check and then I
don't know uh and next you check if it's
possible to attack something that's kind
of the the order that your mind works in
when you're playing a game but here you
know it's just uh I imagine I would be
very sad if I missed a A variation that
starts with check a point is that after
King to B6 it's a forced King Khan Queen
to beat with the check now you can't go
back otherwise you just get the
checkmated with Queen to A6 uh Queen to
A7 so you have to go uh uh to the right
side of the board Queen to C7 check King
to D5 now Knights the F4 check Force the
king further down the board Queen E4
King T4 Queen to C6 with check King to
F5 and now Queen to G6 check forces the
king into the central E5 Square the pawn
covers D4 and F4 and this of course uh
Queen to E6 will be Checkmate so here we
have Queen to C2 by Magnus missing this
idea uh but now Queen to E1 with check
King to H2 and Knight to D2 now trying
to get some sort of um
a checkmating attack against the white
king So King the G3 uh defends the F2
pawn and Knight staff one check with
King the F4 uh the queen guards the the
pawn here with Knight to D2 again
threatening the pawn and the Magnus
again defends it with the king king G3
Knight to F1 would check King to G4 and
not Knights to D2 and now Queen to C3
with check Magnus has to be careful not
to repeat moves and Wesley plays it pawn
to B4 is this one of the B4 moves in the
long line of the winning B4 moves uh
well let's uh let's see what happens
Queen to C5 with check King the A4 and
now Knights the D4 Magnus offers the F2
Pawn as the Knight is covering B3 and B5
so you know that Queen to A7 will be
Checkmate so Wesley cannot afford this
he plays Pawn to B3 and now look at this
queen to B5 with check King to A3 and
now there is only one winning move for
Magnus uh feel free to pause the video
and to win this um incredible uh brawl
uh while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on always looking
for fun ways to give up your queen at
least temporarily and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Queen capture some B3 this is what
Magnus played and now there is nothing
more to be done here uh Wesley captured
Magnus played Knights the C2 with check
and he was in this position on move 56
that Wesley Soul resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
the problem is once the king moves
you're gonna capture the queen and now
you have three points to zero of course
this is completely winning so Wesley uh
unfortunately had to resign here and uh
another victory for uh for Magnus
Carlson who just I mean after uh two uh
you know suspicious um days of of
quality chess of suspicious quality
chess during the Rapids uh he just uh
woke up um you know during in the final
day of the Rapids and also now during
the two days of Blitz absolutely
crushing the field if you guys haven't
seen us then do check it out once again
and uh here you can see that even though
with this spectacular macular you know
achievement he still only wins it uh one
point ahead of Yankees of Duda and
interestingly they went into the last
game of the of the uh of the uh Blitz uh
they faced each other and had Duda won
it would be equal it would be 20. uh uh
Duda would be the one who would uh win
the tournament but in the end the game
ended in a draw and there was nothing
more to be done there but yeah it was it
was a grueling battle I think it lasted
for let me just check 120 24 moves uh
Magnus got a winning Advantage very
early on uh maybe like at move 11 or
something like that and then they went
into a very very long end game then Duda
was completely winning he had a bishop
and two pawns against a rook uh and okay
Magnus just defended well in the end to
do the uh squander the winning Advantage
but it was really wild so if you do have
a chance do check out those uh 124 moves
if you guys really want I can also show
that that game but only if you really
want so yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it nice to see that Magnus
even though he's been away from chess
for a while you know playing poker doing
some other stuff he's still he still has
it and he's able to completely dominate
the field and even almost adopt the the
you know the World Elite uh so yeah
that's the game and uh this short
coverage of the Super Bowl rapper and
Blitz German that was played in Poland
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank John shortlivegolfsoftware.com
ravishing reptiles YouTube
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing at the
checkup on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the Chess
World and thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day